there is a leftist right now
who just attacked another pro-life
women's group uh this happened at 10 p.m
on saturday night
this leftist attacked the concerned
women for america and he did that by
showing up to their
headquarters to their office screaming
yelling flipping them off and then
urinating on their building
exposing himself and urinating on their
building the head of the cwa says
attacks on our employees and our
building will not deter concerned women
for america from standing up for women
and for babies we will not be bullied we
will not back down and we will never
ever stop fighting to protect human life
if you are
a grown man there's video footage of
this by the way if you are a grown man
who shows up and urinates on a
women's organization's building
and screams and yells and shrieks
something has probably gone wrong in the
way you're thinking about things if you
are an adult and you march to a
residential neighborhood to scare a
judge's children
because you don't like a ruling that the
judge may hand down
something has has gone wrong with the
way you're thinking about politics if
you think that the most sacred right
that you have as an american
is
to kill a little baby
no matter all the different
something
has gone wrong with your way of thinking
okay
there was a wonderful response to some
of the left-wing protests in sam alito's
neighborhood so you've got all these
crazy leftists chanting change the
ruling you know trying to influence this
judge's opinion
and
one of sam alito's neighbors instead of
going out and yelling and shrieking at
the protesters he decided to just sit at
his piano and play a hymn
[Applause]
[Music]
you can hear them screaming and
shrieking and going up and down the
residential neighborhood and then you
just hear this me you don't even see him
just hear him inside his home i guess
he's got the window open playing tis so
sweet to trust in jesus
who do you want to be
who do you want who do you think has the
better grasp on reality the crazy
shrieking people with all sorts of
colorful hair and angry clothing and
shrieking and yelling and crying
on the street or the man sitting in his
piano playing a nice hymn of gratitude
to so sweet to trust in jesus it's
obviously the man we should all be this
guy this is the way to do it
he is standing firm he's not fleeing his
house he's not getting out of town he's
not running away to some hotel he's
standing firm
he's not throwing salido his neighbor
under the bus no he stays just he's
there but he is serene
okay he is he is willing to take it he's
not afraid of the mob he's not he's just
going to play tis so sweet to trust in
jesus because
it is
he
and the protesters have very very
different world views
his view which is christianity
used to be the public view of the united
states until very very recently
i know sometimes people say we are not a
christian nation but that's not true we
are obviously a christian nation the
people who founded the country were
almost all christians at the
public ceremonies the public orations
the
ethos the founding documents they all
speak to a christian world view
what the protesters believe in is
secular liberalism leftism that's their
religion it's private and it's public
and they want the public religion of the
united states to be
secular leftism there's a town in brazil
travel with me for a second down to
south america there's a small town in
southern brazil
that just constructed a gigantic statue
of jesus
a statue that is even larger than the
famous christ the redeemer statue in rio
this town is encantado it's a town of 23
000 people in brazil
and they just unveiled the statue statue
christ the protector on april 22nd it
was funded by a local volunteer
organization they spent obviously a lot
of money to build this statue i love it
this really matters why does this matter
this matters even if you're not a
christian
okay this matters if you are just
a normal sane person who doesn't like
the way the left has turned this country
because what this statue represents is
public christianity there is going to be
public belief there is going to be
public ritual okay
i think i think we all get that now a
lot of cultural conservatives have been
saying this for 50 years and
usually just until we're blue in the
face and it doesn't go anywhere but
people are beginning to see that
with the we have public rituals all the
time we have pride parades now it's like
pride quarter of the year it used to be
pride day then pride week then pride
month
now it's like pride three months
we have drag queen story hour is a kind
of public ritual we have public saints
that we venerate like saint george floyd
and others we have this kind of public
role we have the the maxims and the
dogmas of the public religion like
tolerance and diversity and equity and
inclusion right we have all of this
stuff
which religion do you think has given us
the better country
public leftism public liberalism
or public christianity obviously public
christianity you would want to live in
the country that has public christianity
whether you're a christian whether
you're a protestant whether you're
catholic whether you're a jew whether
you're a muslim whether you're an
agnostic atheist normal person who
doesn't want to trans the kids and burn
the country down every six months
if you are any of those things you will
prefer the country with public
christianity so let's do it okay let's
let's drop the charade let's stop
pretending that there is some neutrality
that this was the
uh the last 50 years there was this
experiment that the left proposed and
the right bought it hook line and sinker
that somehow the country is going to be
completely neutral and not take a
position on anything that's why we've
got to kick the bible out of schools in
the mid 20th century that's why we got
to kick prayer out of schools prayer out
of the public square that wasn't true
from the beginning of this country
we had we had all of those things from
the beginning of this country until very
very recently and coincidentally when we
lost all that stuff and when we exalted
liberalism everything went to hell in a
hand basket so maybe it's time
to turn around even if it's not even for
your personal belief do it for the good
of your political society glad you liked
that clip now
ring that smash
like that subscribe click that whatever
you got to click subscribe make sure you
get the notifications head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitch your google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe over there as well if you
don't mind leave a five star review we
will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]